la première
le premier thème de ce matin
et entre mélanie cogner qui est là au
premier rang et qui est une des cent
cinquante citoyenne qui a citoyens
citoyennes jeu pour comme on dit
inclusivement à l'oral bon bref tirés au
sort pour la convention citoyenne sur le
climat qui doit rendre sa copie en avril
si ma mémoire est bonne et votre
serviteur
et là je serai là pour parler un peu du
haut conseil sur le climat bonjour à
tous donc que je j'ai le plaisir
d'animer ce cet échange entre jean marc
et mélanie pour rendre les choses un
petit peu plus vivante et amusante on a
imaginé de mettre des questions dans une
grosse boîte et vous allez tour à tour
pioché dans la boîte et chacun de vous
deux devra répondre à la question donc
si c'est mélanie qui commence
mélanie tu commences à répondre à la
question et après c'est jean-marc de
répondre à la même question il ya six
questions plus une question secrète que
j'ai dans ma poche d'eau dont une sur
une question secrète que j'ai dans ma
poche et que à laquelle vous répondrai
en dernier donc si question ça fait à
peu près 2 minutes chacun pour répondre
jean-marc deux minutes pour répondre à
chaque question oui et je vais mettre
mon chrono
ok donc on va commencer par mélanie
mélanie si tu veux bien tirés au sort et
donc lire la question à voix haute de
pulls ou deux degrés de plus sur le
chauffage toi
et bien moi je suis moi je mets deux
pulls voir un foulard ce qu il fait 18
degrés on ne pose pas le chauffage parce
qu'en fait un degré supplémentaire c'est
10 % de consommation énergétique c'est
ça donc l'idéal pour diminuer les rejets
de co2 c'est de baisser son chauffage
donc l'idéal c'est 19 joueurs degrés la
journée 16 degrés la nuit
aucun ça suffit en mai une bonne couette
un bonnet puis on n'a pas froid comme ça
mais voilà il faudrait que tout le monde
baisse son chauffage et évite de se
promener en tee shirt dans sa maison
l'hiver l'été vous faites ce que vous
voulez mais et mélanie est ce que ça
c'est quelque chose que tu fais depuis
que tu as été à la convention citoyenne
pour le climat où tu avais déjà
conscience de ça avant alors moi j'ai
toujours vécu dans des vieilles baraques
qu'on a rénové donc au fait qui faisait
souvent un peu frais et on s'est habitué
à avoir eu 18 19 quand il fait 20 on a
trop chaud et du coup on le faisait
spontanément mais depuis la convention
jeu mais ça m'a conforté dans l'idée
qu'il faut baisser son faux chauffage
pour réduire les rejets de co2 moi je le
faisais surtout pour réduire ma
consommation d'énergie mais comme tout
est lié
du coup avant la convention je n'avais
pas forcément conscience voilà mais
aujourd'hui plus ça et c'est peut-être
un décret mais tu est chauffée comment
alors nous on est chauffée moitié
électrique avec des radiateurs à inertie
un truc qui je passais mon mari qui fait
ça et sinon on a un poêle à bois avec du
bois des butins pas des granulés parce
que on va pas partir sur l'impact
carbone des granulés mais c'est un poêle
à bois sous les détails c'est des bûches
de 50
on en a beaucoup dans le jardin du bois
voilà et de toute façon moi je voulais
une autonomie
énergétique un sauna je continue on a
connu la tempête de 2009 ans en gironde
donc on est resté huit jours sans
électricité on a vu tous les gens qui
étaient à l'électrique on a dit non on
est content d'avoir une une cheminée est
arrivé en salle j'ai dit à mon mari
tu me remets un truc autonome je veux
rien d'electric parce que si jamais ça
recommence je veux pouvoir avoir chaud
un minimum ok donc on passe à jean-marc
même question deux pulls qu'est-ce qui
va répondre gros suspecte ou c'est aussi
la version un peu plus les deux degrés
en moins oui mais est-ce que tu peux
rentrer un petit peu plus dans le détail
moi je serais intéressé quand même de
savoir si par exemple être chauffé au
bois c'est vraiment bon pour le climat
dans la mesure où on déforeste pas oui
donc en france comme on a une
aujourd'hui une superficie forestière
qui est alors c'est toujours difficile
de savoir exactement la gestion
d'inventaire forestier parce que le
cadastre ne change pas nécessairement
quand on coupe les arbres mais disons
qu'en france dans la limite du
raisonnable oui se chauffer au bois
c'est une bonne idée et par ailleurs se
chauffer à l'électricité c'est aussi
globalement moins carboné que les autres
solutions
mais alors pourquoi je pose une question
naïve
pourquoi ségolène royal avait dit il
faut pas se chauffer faut pas faire de
feu de bois à paris alors ça c'est très
différent
d'abord ce qu'elle voulait interdire
c'est lé foyer ouvert c'est-à-dire la
fameuse cheminée devant laquelle on se
loge dans une couverture là parce que le
rendement de ce genre de cheminée est
très mauvais le rendement d'un poêle à
bois fermés ou d'un insert moderne et
très bon ça se balade entre 60 et 80 %
le reste des calories perdues dans la
lah jeunes à fumer une cheminée ouverte
on est plutôt sur 5 à 10% rendement
c'est-à-dire que le reste est perdu il
va chauffer les petits oiseaux et la
deuxième raison c'était une raisons
sanitaires
il faut savoir que les logements en
france et les premières sources de
particules fines devant les transports
et les cheminées à bois
j'ai envie de dire en foyer ouvert sont
des grosses sources de passer dé rossi
arrête donc c'est des grosses sources de
particules fines mais pas en foyer fermé
non parce que la température de flamme
est plus élevé et en fait les particules
fines c'est la marque d'une température
de combustion qui n'est pas très élevé
c'est plus la température de combustion
est élevée et moins il reste deux
composés organiques y compris sous forme
de particules
dans ce qui dans ce cas tu es mis
d'accord c'est une recirculation dans
les foyers fermés qui permettent de
brûler un maximum de noms mais surtout
la température de combustion est
beaucoup plus élevé et donc c'est sale
c'est ça qui fait la différence et 10
secondes pour dire quelle est la
meilleure façon de se chauffer la
meilleure façon de se chauffer ça va
beaucoup dépendre de la situation de
départ
quand on est chauffée avec un mélange
d'électricité bois c'est parfait on y
est la pompe à chaleur c'est également
quelque chose qui est très bien quand on
est au fuel le simple fait de passer au
gaz c'est déjà mieux le fait de passer à
l'électricité c'est encore mieux enfin
la pompe à chaleur c'est encore mieux
et puis par ailleurs pour rebondir sur
sur le début il faut essayer de se
chauffer en mettant pas d enfin il faut
entre 2 degrés et le pull il faut
essayer d'offrir le pull donc tout est
relatif et tout dépend tout dépend de la
ou pas donc deuxième question cette fois
ci c'est jean-marc qui tire maintenant
plus mais je pense que je vais réussir à
léguer c'est facile
à quoi sert la convention citoyenne pour
le climat c'est à moi de répondre à
cette question non en fait c'est à quoi
sert le haut conseil
voilà et mélanie alors il ya la réponse
formelle et la réponse taquine la
réponse formelle en ce qui concerne le
haut conseil c'est que nous devons
donner une fois par an un avis sur la
trajectoire des missions de la france
sas à la réponse formelle la réponse
taquine c'est que je pense que c'est un
truc de plus que macron à trouver pour
gagner du temps et en ce qui concerne la
convention citoyenne pour le climat je
pense que malheureusement il ya aussi
une réponse formelle et une réponse
taquiner je pense que la deuxième
réponse est aussi partiellement vrai
d'accord mais donc pour la convention
mélanie verts répondent pour le haut
conseil tu peux nous en dire un peu plus
oui le alors le haut-conseil comment ça
marche
en fait il ya un conseil lui-même est
une équipe qui travaille donc il ya six
permanents aujourd'hui c'est de mémoire
au conseil qui font l'essentiel de la
production écrite le haut conseil
lui-même c'est douze ou treize personnes
treize personnes maintenant on sait pas
qui est judas qui se réunissent une fois
par mois sous la présidence de corinne
le quéré qui est une franco canadienne
installée en bretagne comme ça un pied
partout et qui est on essaye de de
fournir des avis donc on a la
possibilité à la fois enfin on a un
mandat j'ai envie dire formelle qui est
de rendre une fois par an un rapport un
peu structurée dans lequel on raconte
des choses on peut s'autosaisir si on le
souhaite sur des sujets haddock
donc on peut décider qu'on va répondre à
une question que personne nous a posés
et on est également tenu de répondre aux
saisines gouvernementale par exemple
elisabeth bornes nous a envoyé il ya
quelques mois
enfin il ya quasiment un an une question
qui était comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour avoir des méthodes
d'évaluation etc santé des lois quant à
un impact significatif sur le climat le
fonctionnement on se réunit donc une
fois par mois et on a assigné j'ai envie
de dire les membres du haut conseil pour
un jour
deux réunions plus les annexes pendant
c'est au moins en ce qui me concerne
totalement bénévole je crois qu'il y
avait une indemnité qui était prévu mais
je ne suis plus enfin bon bref je sais
que corinne est rémunéré pour ça mais
c'est normal parce qu'elle a une charge
beaucoup plus lourde les autres membres
gentil les gens suivent enfin je peu
près personne ne l'ait je crois est
votre rôle c'est ce n'est pas
d'intervenir dans l'actualité ou en tout
cas quand il se passe quelque chose
d'important vos concernant parce que par
exemple il ya quelques temps le
gouvernement a dit bon bah finalement la
snb si on va pas la respecter dans le
prochain on va augmenter le quota bien
et il ya eu il n'y a pas eu de réaction
dans fcc
non alors c'est un débat entre nous
c'est un débat entre nous parce qu'à
partir du moment où on choisit
d'intervenir dans l'actualité ça
augmente d'un facteur 5 à 10 le temps
qu'il faut il passer
donc c'est donc c'est voilà donc pour le
moment l'option qui a été prise c'est de
ne pas le faire mais là c'était quand
même un gros truc
oui je redis à partir du moment où on
s'invite dans l'actualité
ça veut dire que il faut accepter d'y
passer du temps parce que ça veut dire
qu'on devient visible c'est même le but
du jeu et si on devient visible en est
sollicité donc ça nécessite d'y passer
du temps je dis pas que c'est une bonne
ou une mauvaise option je dis juste
voilà l'option qui a été prise et la
raison pour laquelle elle a été prise
c'est une question de gestion du temps
et c'est une question de posture
également parce que
pour le moment l'option qui a été prise
et celle d'être un organisme qui n'est
qu'en dire justement qui n'est pas là
pour réagir à des trucs de court terme
mais pour avoir un un positionnement un
peu installé sur des pas de temps un peu
plus long est ce que ça sera utile ça
c'est un autre débat mais ces salles
option n'était plus d'accord ok donc
mélanie à quoi sert la convention
citoyenne pour le climat alors moi
d'abord j'ai une question qui a déjà
entendu parler de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat avant
aujourd'hui un pas super non là je suis
content parce qu'en général quand j'en
parle autour de moi on dit non je bois
je pense que c'est donc c'est bien fut
bien je vais rester toute la journée
donc la convention citoyenne vous savez
ce que c'est c'est un regroupement de
150 personnes tirées au sort pour
produire des mesures qui pourront être
transformée en loi décret ou référendum
qui est un terroriste seront présentées
sans filtre à l'assemblée nationale
c'est ce que nous a dit le président
mais bon on a appris depuis que ce
serait lui ont fait le filtre donc ce
sera lui le filtre et nous a dit qu'ils
allaient à oran va lui rendre nos
mesures le 4 5 avril et plus tard il
veut nous revoir pour nous dire ce
qu'ils gardent ou pas donc en fait c'est
lui le filtre c'est pas l'assemblée
nationale donc l'ordre de mission c'est
réduire d'au moins 40 % les rejets de
co2 d'ici 2030 dans un esprit de justice
sociale par rapport à 1990 donc mais
nous on est on sait dit d'abord on s'est
dit on prend pas en compte que les
rejets de la france
on prend lé entre l'empreinte carbone et
ensuite on s'est dit on ne prend pas par
rapport à 90 ont fait le maximum de ce
qu'on peut qu'on peut donner et si on
est à 40 % par rapport au jour d'hui ce
qu'il ne sait pas mais voilà donc
commencé en fait on veut faire le
maximum
alors ça pourra avoir un on sera
peut-être pas très très très bien perçu
quand on déposera les mesures début
avril que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont qui vont trouver que ce
sont des mesures liberticides
mais bon comme je les dis un début de
session 5 bat c'est la guerre quoi donc
il faut prendre des mesures pour réduire
vraiment les rejets de co2
après nous les mesures qu'on va proposer
comme je dis c'est on sait pas si ce
sera appliqué effectivement on a
conscience qu'on est peut-être là juste
pour faire joli pour mais on fait ce
qu'on peut
mais il ya vraiment parmi les 150
citoyens un consensus général pour aller
très loin pour être radicales pour être
liberticide où il ya différents courants
il ya quand même un consensus général
on n'est pas après il ya des mesures qui
équipe qui peuvent être plus au début
nous il ya des mesures qu'on a on a
commencé à les étudier on s'est dit non
ça c'est pas possible c'est trop fort ça
passera jamais et au final quand on
s'est rendu compte de l'impact on nous a
expliqué hé bien tout le monde les a
acceptées donc ce que je dis tout le
temps c'est que si on a si on informe si
on explique avant d'imposer il ya de
grandes chances que les mesures passent
et dans la convention ces sables dans
les 150 c'est au début on se dit non
mais on a une mesure lac est forte
une qui nous disent mais ça passera
jamais peut-être que si on l'expliquent
ou si on y va doucement ça finira par
passer
donc du coup aux annonces a fait
consensus quand même et puis on arrive à
discuter entre nous et à se convaincre
les uns les autres et parce qu'en fait
on est cinq groupes de travail se
déplaçait se nourrir travailler produire
se loger consommer et donc chaque groupe
de trente étudier ces monsieurs préparer
ces mesures et donc les autres groupes
viennent nous voir mais ça pour quoi que
vous avez fait ça quel est l'impact à
quoi ça va servir comment ça va passer
du coup on échange on partage et je
trouve que c'est wade ça va finir sur un
consensus et
et plutôt radicale ouais enfin je garde
l'espoir mais ouais et bourg pour
revenir juste à la question vraiment de
base à quoi sert la ccc si jamais c'est
possible le filtre est très gros et que
vous êtes hyper déçu est ce que vous
avez imaginé d'ores et déjà des moyens
de réagir ou de mobiliser l'opinion
publique ou d'autres politiques ou le
chili jean-marc il ya 250 personnes qui
nous soutiennent
moi depuis le début ce que je dis c'est
de en fait on a commencé début octobre
moi depuis le début je communique dans
la presse j'ai rencontré députés
sénateurs la population vendredi soir
j'ai fait la première soirée convention
à sablé sur sarthe on avait 1 % de la
population c'est-à-dire 150 personnes
mais en fait il faut que depuis le début
on se dit tout ce qu'il faut il faut
fédérer la population il faut informer
un maximum sur la convention parce que
c'est pas 150 qu'on aura un poids sur le
gouvernement sait si un maximum de
personnes est informé et c'est ce qu'on
fait et pourquoi on le fait là il y aura
un impact donc ce qu'on fera exactement
on sait pas on va pas à sortir les armes
avant de savoir si c'est validé mais
nous on a l'intention de suivre nos
mesures derrière de toute façon et puis
on verra ce qu'on fait le moment venu
mais voilà depuis le début on essaye de
communiquer autour de nous et fédérer un
maximum de personnes pour avoir
peut-être pas toute la france derrière
nous mais on espère donc ok parfait
vivre donc le message c'est parlez-en
autour de vous thomas l'a oubliée
communiqué on a pris un petit peu de
temps sur ces deux questions parce
qu'elle était importante mais donc on
continue
mélanie cette lettre
une carte de crédit pour mesurer son
empreinte carbone
alors je sais pas si c'était en fait
c'est une carte de crédit qui existe
dans un pays je crois que c'est le
danemark elle s'appelle d'autonomie je
sais pas si elle est très utilisée mais
c'est sur le principe qu'en penses tu
bah ça peut être une bonne façon de
mesurer son empreinte carbone dans ses
achats mais
les limites c'est pour le coup là c'est
sûr volontariat on a on a été abordé à
la convention on a eu des personnes nous
ont contactés pour parler de la carte
carbone après nous on a étudié un peu le
truc con
mais on s'est dit que c'était pas on
nous dit que c'est qu'ils tablent
justice sociale et tout mais c'est pas
vraiment on a considéré que c'était pas
vraiment équitable dans le sens où c'est
encore les plus riches qui peuvent
racheter du carbone aux autres alors là
cette carte carbone d'autonomie c'est
sur du volontariat mais donc c'est
forcément les gens qui sont conscients
qu'ils qui s'en serviront et qui
pourront faire varier leurs rejets de
co2 via ça mais ça peut pas concerner
tout le monde
toute la question c'est est-ce que cette
carte serait obligatoire et sans pouvoir
racheter le crédit d autres jean-marc
qu'est ce que tu penses de 7,2 cette
piste
j'ai un petit parallèle à faire on a
tous un compte en banque
on va à peu près tous un compte en
banque et pour gérer un compte en banque
par français c'est à dire quelque chose
qui permet de compter d euros avec des
plus et des moins il faut quoi 200 ou
300 milles banquiers dans ce pays
donc je pense que si on avait tous un
compte en carbone avec un quota
indépendamment des questions d'équité
alloués en début d'année et ensuite une
comptabilité très précise du décompte de
ce quota en fonction de ce qu'on
consomme
il faudrait aussi de l'ordre de 200 à
300 mille personnes pour gérer le
système que je pense que ça va être un
tout petit peu long à mettre en place et
donc je pense que malheureusement c'est
quelque chose qui est pas compatible
avec les pas de temps qu'on a devant
nous donc personnellement je suis
beaucoup plus favorable et aux chiffres
on travaille plutôt là dessus sur des
mesures qui sont à large spectre assez
bien ciblées qui tape dans les postes
principaux et qui sont beaucoup plus des
obligations de moyens qu'une
comptabilité très précises fait personne
par personne parce qu'en fait pour que
ce truc là marche ça s'apparente à un
rationnement oui c'est le système des
tickets de rationnement tout est fait
pour gérer correctement un système de
tickets de rationnement il faut beaucoup
de monde descola donc c'est ça le
indépendamment de la question de
l'équité donc cesser - le principal
inconvénient que je vois ce truc là
sans compter que par ailleurs compte
tenu du niveau de compréhension du
problème dans la population dans son
ensemble et ça je pense que c'est
l'enseignement majeur moi que je tire de
l'expérience convention citoyenne pour
le climat il faut d'abord passer par la
compréhension du problème avant qu'on
puisse discuter de la moindre du moindre
truc un peu contraignant et ce qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas le cas pour la
population dans son ensemble donc on
peut toujours discuter de ce genre de
trucs mais je pense que c'est une
discussion un peu sur le cette saison je
crois pour moi c'est sûr qu'en fin
mélanie est ce que est effectivement
l'urgence est pas que tous les tous les
français suivent la même formation que
vous avez eu le premier week-end où je
t'ai entendu dire que vous aviez pris
quand même une grosse claque et que
c'est effectivement nous c'est en fait
le premier week-end on a eu donc mises à
jour sur l'état de la planète le co2 est
le deuxième week-end on a eu on a évalué
les leviers les contraintes et on s'est
dit qu'un des gros levier pour réduire
les rejets de co2 ce serait la
communication et l'information de toute
la population parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pas du tout le cas alors il y en a
compris vraiment une claque le premier
week-end parce que je sais pas où il
habite mais parmi les dépôts courant
qu'il y avait un problème avec le
réchauffement climatique et ensuite il
ya aussi le fait que
enfin il faut vraiment vraiment informé
passer une fois qu'ils ont été informés
il est on y est et on est tous au taquet
c'est ce qu'on dit là c'est tout le
monde est pour
faux faux faux pour la réduction du co2
alors qu'il ya des gens qui étaient même
climato sceptiques en arrivant c'est qui
qui croyons pas trop que non franchement
c'était et la question c'était c'est bon
en a maintenant
mais c'est quand même une très bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'une fois qu'on a pris
conscience et qu'on ait informé on est
ok pour y aller ah oui oui c'est
pourquoi je le dis tout le temps plein
et temps tout le temps il faut informer
il faut communiquer moi moi je m'en sors
bien je communique mais il faut
absolument parler partout autour de vous
voyez des gens qui me disent mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour la convention
vous communiquez vous parlez vous dit ce
qu'est la convention vous informer sur
le changement climatique sur l'urgence
surtout parce qu'il ya aussi sayah le
réchauffement climatique ok mais ya
plein de gens qui se disent pour nous
encore le temps ça fait quarante ans
qu'on nous dit que c'est réchauffement
climatique
donc non non non vous mais nous on va
passer à la question suivante
merci je remarque
à pied en vélo ou à cheval basse vallée
évidemment puisque je les gars est
devant mais pas vu c'est quoi la
question c'est qu'est ce que je fais ou
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
les deux mon général moi j'ai de la
chance je suis un csp + donc quand j'ai
déménagé en dehors de paris où je ne me
déplaçais quasiment jamais en voiture
j'avais une j'étais obligée de rester
dans la région parisienne et j'avais un
cahier des charges qui était je vais à
distance marchande des transports en
commun donc ça a été et chacun sait que
le prix de l'immobilier augmentent quand
on est à distance marchande des
transports en commun et moi j'avais
cette chance et donc c'est exactement ce
que j'ai fait donc je ne prends à peu
près quasiment jamais la voiture or pour
partir en vacances puisque là j'ai pas
encore gagné le combat
et sinon j'ai donc en région parisienne
va déplacent à pied en vélo depuis la
grève
je me suis mis un peu plus aux vélos
rouges avaient très bien pour ses motos
vélos et puis en transports en commun
quand je me déplace en france et
transport en commun train je refuse
systématiquement les conférences où il
faut prendre l'avion et je vois là à peu
près tout cas pas pris l'avion depuis
combien de temps j'ai pas pris l'avion
depuis quelques années la dernière fois
que les prix c'était parce que j'avais
une fille en stage à l'étranger et que
je n'ai pas su négocier pour y aller en
train voilà mais sinon à part ça ça doit
faire je pars
pour des raisons personnelles se doit
faire 20 ans ou 25 ans j'ai pas mis les
pieds dans un avion pour des raisons
personnelles et professionnellement
j'essaye de le limiter vraiment au
maximum maximorum et qu est-ce que t'as
pas l'impression que cette question de
mobilité elle et elle est vraiment perçu
par les gens comme la plus liberticide
j'ai bien sûr faut quand même rappeler
qu'on est des animaux et qu'on se
déplace et du reste les statistiques
montrent que depuis aussi longtemps
qu'il ya des statistiques
les gens font trois déplacements par
jour alors si je pusse et 3,8 enfin bon
bref
mais on fait trois déplacements par jour
en moyenne et on a on est câblé pour se
comporter comme ça et par ailleurs on se
déplace en moyenne une heure par jour et
on est câblé pour se comporter comme ça
et donc quand on augmente la performance
des moyens de transport combien d'autres
dispositions on se déplace pas moins
longtemps pour faire la même chose on se
déplace aussi longtemps pour les plus
loin donc la manière qu'on a de se
comporter est une manière biologique
encore une fois on est des animaux se
déplacent trois fois par jour et donc
les marges de manoeuvre qu'on a là
dessus c'est de se déplacer moins loin
avec des modes guide ne vendent moins
d'énergie et voilà c'est ça laisse à
penser qu'on va supprimer des
déplacements ça marchera pas parce qu'on
est des animaux mélanie sur cette
question moi j'ai votre cheval mais je
suis en voiture ce que j'habite à la
campagne entre guillemets dans la
province pour vous ici j'habite du côté
de sablé sur sarthe à 5 km et c'est pas
loin 5 km pour aller faire ses courses
en vélo sauf qu'il n'y a pas de piste
cyclable c'est une départementale avec
des bons gros camions qui sont censés
roule à 80 mais c'est plutôt 90 donc
voilà c'est la voiture chez nous j'ai
projet d'acheter un vélo à assistance
électrique pourrait essayer de me faire
écraser sur la départementale on verra
ce que ça donne et voilà nous en milieu
rural on n'a pas accès aux mobilités
douces du tout c'est mais pareil le
collège est à 6 km de la maison les
enfants pourraient y aller en vélo mais
non c'est trop dangereux
donc j'ai demandé l'autre coup on a vu
un monsieur qui était responsable des
infrastructures du transport et de la
mer j'ai demandé une piste cyclable de
chez moi jusqu'à à l'école j'ai pas vu
les camions encore j'attends mais ouais
non pour dire en milieu rural on n'a pas
pas le choix on faire du covoiturage et
créé un petit groupe covoiturage de mon
village
en fait on est deux à partager dessus au
lieu de m'envoyer un sms
mon collègue essaye de découpe de
communiquer sur la page facebook pour
montrer aux gens qu'il faut se bouger
mais c'est pendant que ça fera partie
j'imagine des mesures que vous qui
seront dans la to do list donné à
emmanuel macron dernière question alain
secondes de pub
le shift vient de faire un rapport sur
la manière de passer de l'auto sol à
n'importe quoi d'autre justement dans
les zones de moyenne densité qui a été
publié il ya quelques semaines voilà des
essais ont évidemment on l'a publié à
l'occasion des municipales
il est d'ailleurs super nous on est en
zone de très faible densité 640
habitants dans mon village il n'y a pas
de bussy rien il faudra le prochain ce
sera ça ces zones de très faible densité
le chef de la viande ou des lentilles
donc ça dépend souvent c'est pour
réduire les rejets de co2 c'est les
lentilles forcément ça que des avantages
dans la culture dans l'alimentation m'a
pressé c'est jean-marc qui donne les
chiffres mais l'avant avant nous enfin
moi j'avais conscience déjà peut les
manger moins de viande mais mon mari
voulait un petit morceau de viande tous
les jours et aujourd'hui
depuis qu'ils regardent la convention il
nous suit il a pris conscience de
beaucoup de choses en fait il était un
peu plus de retard par rapport à moi ils
pacsés l'écoféminisme et du coup j'avais
un peu de mal
normalement commencer juste un couple
normal on la sait ça exactement
donc il ya un peu de mal à comprendre
pourquoi il faut manger moins de viande
pourquoi vous achetez une gourde
pourquoi faut arrêter les bouteilles en
plastique et là c'est bon tout est
validé on mange de la viande deux fois
par semaine le reste du temps j'ai fait
le coup des lentilles au curry l'a dit
c'est super bon bah ouais tu vois ça se
mange
et donc voilà n'hésitez pas à informer
vos époux qu'enfin ya pas beaucoup de
femmes là aujourd'hui si quand même
non pas trop parce que ce serait les
femmes qui ferait avec lui parce que
c'est l'écoféminisme parce que le souci
le souci j'ai remarqué dans beaucoup
beaucoup de couples ça le l'écologie
arrive parle
voilà c'est peut-être que c'est valable
qu'en province je sais pas moi j'habite
en province est ce que c'est vrai dans
tous les couples jean-marc la réponse
est non et par ailleurs mélanie a raison
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
coupe où c'est la femme qui commande
entre lee même si c'est pas elle qui
fait la cuisine mais qui courent on
arrêtera là bon jeu on va passer vite
sur la dernière question parce que je il
faudrait quand même laisser du temps
mais moi je ne parle pas des lentilles
et du boeuf si si non moi je voulais
faire un deux ou trois complément
effectivement le cheptel bovin c'est la
moitié de l'empreinte carbone de
l'alimentation d'un français donc c'est
quelque chose de très important
mais vous savez aussi que les éleveurs
font partie des paysans qui sont les
plus pauvres et où il ya les taux de
suicide les plus élevés donc dire
simplement on va manger moins de viande
toutes choses égales par ailleurs c'est
un truc qui va pas leur rendre service
et c'est pas ça qu'il a repeuplé les
campagnes et donc il faut absolument que
ce mouvement sur manger moins de viande
ce qui est effectivement nécessaire ou
d'actes mans diminuer la taille du
cheptel bovin s'accompagne de mesures
qui font que ça ne se fait pas au
détriment des éleveurs et donc il ya
également toute la partie politique a
pensé autour de ça et notamment
moi je milite maintenant pour un système
qui ressemblerait à celui qu'on a sur
les nerfs c'est à dire qu'il y ait des
prix garantis en sortie de ferme
garantie par les collectivités en
échange de cahier des charges pour que
les éleveurs face les choses comme il
faut c'est-à-dire label bio pas de soja
fin tout ce qu'on veut un élevage moins
intensifs - de tête par personne mais
des prix au kilo beaucoup plus élevés
pour les éleveurs de telle sorte qu'il
ya une plus d'argent et qu'on remette de
la valeur ajoutée dans les exploitations
voilà donc il suffit pas de dire je vais
manger moins de viande ce que je fais
aussi je pense qu'il ya aussi tout un
tout un sujet à concevoir autour de ça
je pas si la convention à un groupe
agriculture ou pas mais il ya tout un
sujet à concevoir autour de ça qui est
comment est ce qu'on arrive à sortir du
de la situation dans laquelle on a mis
les éleveurs et là on a un vrai sujet
avec le libéralisme à l'européenne qui
consiste à faire sur un certain nombre
de sujets on n'habite plus tôt l'
inverse de ce qu'il faudrait faire
oui et puis en plus je crois enfin je
suis pas une spécialiste mais je crois
qu'on a encore besoin des vaches pour
brouter les prairies
une présentation très intéressante ici
même il ya quelques mois d'un chercheur
au lead au laboratoire
interdisciplinaire des énergies de
demain qui s'appelle pedros le simpi
roos la vidéo est disponible sur
internet en basse définition évidemment
dans lequel il expliquait que dans un
monde sans combustibles fossiles en fait
les amendements aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que le gaz naturel mais le gaz
sert à faire les engrais azotés qui
permette d'amender les sols et les
engrais potassium et phosphore viennent
par ailleurs de mines
c'est à dire que c'est transporté sur
très longue distance grâce au pétrole
dans un monde avec beaucoup moins
d'énergies fossiles en fait
historiquement les amendements venait
des animaux donc si vous n'avez plus
d'animaux du tout vous avez un sujet sur
la fertilisation du sol
donc il ya aussi un équilibre à trouver
avec le cheptel c'est pas juste une
affaire voilà il faut il faut regarder
le système dans son ensemble c'est
justement pour ça que c'est compliqué ok
donc au passé la dernière question qui
est là et je vais la lire
quelle question avez vous le plus envie
de poser à l'autre qui commence oui
alors moi je demanderais bien jean-marc
quel est votre empreinte carbone votre
bilan carbone
il ya longtemps je n'ai pas fait
il ya trois postes sur lesquels à mon
avis je suis bon et impose sur le catch
est pas bon les trois postes sur
lesquels je suis bon c'est la
consommation de produits manufacturés
parce qu'il ya deux espèces d'hommes il
ya ce qu'il faut traîner dans les
magasins et ceux qui courent et moi je
fais partie de la première donc j'ai pas
eu beaucoup et me forcer la deuxième
chose sur laquelle je pense que je suis
pas trop mauvaise et l'alimentation
parce que j'ai notamment
considérablement réduit la consommation
de viande rouge j'en mange quasiment
plus depuis très longtemps et le
troisième poste sur lequel doit pas être
trop mauvaise et les déplacements le
poste sur lequel je suis pas bon c'est
le chauffage
parce que maintenant que les enfants
sont partis on est dans une grande
maison chauffée au gaz et donc ça ça va
pas du tout satisfaite de la réponse
joe g pâtit non parce qu'il faudrait que
je il faudrait que je le refasse je
crois de mémoire quand on l'a fait avec
ma is you to que j'étais aux alentours
de 7 ou 8 tonnes par an le 2 mai tout
compris du comprimé donc là oui je
remarque une question à mélanie moi j'ai
envie de poser la question qui est à vos
yeux le la
la chose qui sera la plus intéressante
dans le fait d'avoir vécu la convention
citoyenne pour le climat c'est quoi
alors si les rencontres humaines que
toutes les personnes les 150 de la
convention tous les gens qu'on rencontre
au ce2 tous les gens que j'ai rencontrés
la clé tout comme ça moi je suis
vachement dans l'humain j'ai un métier
qui fait que je suis dans l'humain je
suis auxiliaire de vie à domicile est en
fait j'adore rencontrer des gens des
nouvelles personnes et je trouve que le
plus enrichissant ça a été ça et puis
après
apprendre tout ce que j'ai appris toutes
les informations que j'ai pu je suis
allé à l'école un petit peu mais c'était
il ya vingt ans je fais un iut que j'ai
pas eu mais bon bref génie des procédés
et ça faisait longtemps que je n'avais
pas remis en route mon cerveau et du
coup ça c'était aussi hyper satisfaisant
de d'apprendre tous ces trucs tous deux
mois j'étais sur le groupe se déplacer
donc j'ai plein plein plein
d'informations sur comment réduire son
co2 donc toutes les informations que
j'ai reçues et toutes les personnes que
j'ai rencontrées c'est deux choses hyper
intéressante
on peut imaginer que vous allez vous
revoir d'ailleurs pour certains parce
que ça va être une fois que les 150
points ouais bah oui on peut pas se
laisser comme ça on est très loin les
uns des autres mais
en fait on a le projet de monter une
association des 150 pour pouvoir
justement continuer à te voir
d'ailleurs je suis à la havane
c'était quand mi-février lâcher les
chercher mon fils à vannes et il y à une
des cent cinquante havane donc on a bu
un café toutes les deux en fait qu'on
aille n'importe où n'importe où en
france on a quelqu'un qui est pas loin
qu'il ya moins de 50 kilomètres de là on
est donc après oui on veut on veut se
monte en association pour garder le
contact et continuer à se voir
suivent les mesures éventuellement
pourcher pas à faire continuer
l'information sur le réchauffement
climatique et l'urgence on se lassera
pas que collectif des 150
voilà par exemple il n'a pas encore
déterminé de nom de je ne sais quoi mais
on a un petit peu de temps pour les
questions est ce que quelqu'un veut
poser
des questions à mélanie et jean-marc
alors là il ya madame en bleu merci
bonjour en fait moi je voudrais savoir
si on pourrait hiérarchiser les
priorités dans les mesures de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre est ce que ce
serait d'abord la mobilité ensuite la
rénovation thermique des logements
la consommation numérique donc en
fonction des postes de rejet de gaz à
effet de serre en france les plus gros
émetteurs c'est les transports avec 31%
donc c'est il faudrait d'abord réduire
les transports
ensuite c'est les logements donc on a le
deuxième poste logement le numérique ça
arrive loin derrière parce qu'entre
temps on a quand même
l'alimentation l'agriculture on a aussi
la consommation mais ça c'est plutôt sur
l'empreinte carbone donc quoi les
premiers postes réduction c'est la
voiture particulière c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que le chiffre entre autres a
fait un guide de mobilité bas carbone
voilà jean-marc dit dont la synthèse est
disponible au fond de la salle moi je
vais revenir sur l'une des choses les
plus importantes qui a été dit par
mélanie c'est qu'en fait il ya pas de
passage à l'action si les gens n'ont pas
envie d'y passer et pour avoir envie d'y
passer il faut comprendre dans quelle
situation on est une fois qu'on a
compris dans quelle situation en est on
a envie d'agir partout donc là la
question en fait un sans vouloir être
impoli et quelque part elle a pas de
sens parce que ou bien on a vraiment
envie de s'y coller et à ce moment on
s'attaque à tout et ça devient un projet
politique au sens noble du terme c'est à
dire on a une vision sur la manière dont
on a envie d'organiser l'avenir et on
met ça devient un critère de tri ça
devient un critère de passage à l'action
ça devient un critère de d'apprentissage
et de compétences à des fins voilà ça
devient un critère de tout quoi
ou bien on n'a pas envie et à ce moment
on bricole de manière cosmétiques et la
question n'a pas non plus de sens parce
que finalement il ya rien qui est plus
important que le reste rien est
important finalement c'est ça passe
après tout le reste est à chaque fois
qu'on a un conflit d'objectif entre la
question climat est autre chose et on
arbitre en faveur d'autres choses
bonjour donc le tilt perret je suis
étudiante entrepreneuse est ingénieur
chimiste de formation et j'ai une
question par rapport à la convention
citoyenne pour le climat je voulais
savoir entre la paix enfin le temps de
dépôt de votre proposition est le retour
du président donc il va a priori faire
un filtre quelle est cette durée et si
pendant cette période là vous aurez la
possibilité de communiquer en masse et
si vous avez des stratégies de
communication
voilà pour rendre justement un peu
public toute cette proposition est
potentiellement avoir plus de personnes
dans la balance pour faire de ce hameau
faire pression mais au moins pourrait
pour peser un peu plus on n'a pas encore
le planning de retour de
du président de la république ensuite on
a prévu de communiquer oui mon enfin là
pour le moment on n'a pas le droit de
communiquer sur les mesures que rien
n'est validée à 150 donc on va pas dire
voilà mais on a prévu 2 personnellement
oui et puis tout fait on est on est
quand même une minorité a communiqué à
faire dès ce qu'on appelle les climats
perron mai
on a prévu de plein de trucs
dès qu'on va avoir le droit d'en parler
ça va être vous allez être submergé
d'informations
oui bonjour r&d bercegol physicien une
question pour ménager y consigner dans
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
est ce que vous vous êtes contenté de
parler de ce que les français peut se
faire ou de ce que en france on peut
faire pour faire en sorte que le
problème climatique soit résolu au
niveau de la planète
je m'explique essentiellement les
émetteurs et plus on va aller plus ça
sera le cas sont les pays qui veulent se
développer
donc il faut faire du développement
parce que ces pays là vont pas arrêter
de se développer on parle de voilà un
milliard de milliards de fréquents etc
donc est-ce que vous avez parlé de ça ou
pas alors nous notre mandat c'est sûr la
france donc à l'origine c'est vraiment
les émissions de co2 de la france on
april entre l'empreinte carbone des
français pour les informer des
importations des produits de
consommation mais on ne peut pas faire
de recommandations pour les pays en voie
de développement où ça fait pas partie
de notre lettre de mission déjà
on a sept wickens et ses shows comme on
dit on aurait pu en avoir cinq six de
plus ça aurait été aussi bien mais non
déjà enfin en fait un week-end de
travail on en a six parce que le
week-end crs restitution des le dernier
ces restitutions des mesures donc ben on
n'a pas eu le temps sera peut-être une
autre convention parce que le but aussi
c'est que les conventions citoyenne soit
pérennisée et qui on est de plus en plus
dans le futur
remarque un mot là-dessus non c'est pas
du tout non plus la mission de htc est
ce que ça peut paraître limitant ou
frustrant nous on a exactement la même
feuille de route c'est à dire qu'on nous
demande d'avoir un avis sur la
trajectoire des missions de la france et
la trajectoire des missions c'est au
sens de la convention climat donc c'est
aussi des émissions domestiques
donc de temps en temps on s'autorise
d'avoir des avis sur l'empreinte carbone
mais globalement c'est les émissions
domestiques qui sont dans le qui sont
l'objet de notre mandat oui parce que là
la cccc des emplois c'est l'empreinte
globale
ah non la convention citoyenne c'est les
rejets de co2 des français mais nous en
fait on s'est saisi de l'empreinte
carbone
d'ailleurs quand le président de la
république une de mes collègues annie
lui a demandé si on pouvait tenir compte
de l'empreinte carbone il ya du
mouvement ça veut rien dire parce que
mais non nous dans le sens c'est ça
c'est x 2e loin donc relocalisation des
industries tout ça tout ça on en parle
mais un hoquet une dernière question on
a le temps on pas oui oui ok bonjour
jean paul le glaive dans vos réflexions
quid de la prise en compte de cette
problématique dans les programmes
scolaires dans l'enseignement pour pour
une prise de conscience le plus tôt
possible des enfants des élèves
voilà c'est à qui la question à qui veut
bien répondre jeu
alors nous c'est un des premiers points
qu'on a abordé dès le début
l'information dès le départ de
l'essentiel le principal c'est quand
même d'informer la jeunesse à l'école et
apparemment moi je discutais avec un
prof de svt je croque lima perron du
mois de décembre à paris qui disait que
c'est dans les programmes en fait le
réchauffement climatique vient
d'ailleurs j'ai un truc à vous dire
c'est dans les programmes
mais du coup ils le font puis comme il
voit qu'il ya pas d'impact les profs moi
c'est ce que m'a dit cette prof là je
mets pas tous les profs dans le même
panier apparemment comme ça pas d'impact
bail en a qu'on arrêtait d'un
d'information le réchauffement
climatique parce qu'il pense que ça sert
à rien et donc jean marc g mafiques 5e
et le prof a pris comme extrait un
morceau d'un livre écrit par jean marc
jancovici la différence entre le climat
et et la météo
on va prendre deux dernières questions
sauf contre ordre de la part de moi j'ai
juliette ou impératif g1j un complément
là-dessus aux chiffres on a travaillé
sur l'enseignement supérieur est en fait
la question de la formation n'est pas
limiter l'enseignement initial primaire
et secondaire
il ya également année dans vos sujets
dans les entreprises moi il ya un truc
que je dis souvent c'est qu'une
entreprise qui prétend être sérieuses
sur la question ne l'est pas tant que la
totalité de son encadrement n'est pas
passé par dix heures de cours pour
comprendre de quoi on parle
donc il ya là aussi hélas ça ne dépend
que du patron de dire oui effectivement
on va faire ça donc pour tous les gens
qui sont dans les entreprises il ya un
truc qu'on peut très bien demander au
sein d'une entreprise ça dépend pas de
l'éducation nationale et ça dépend pas
que je sais pas quoi c'est juste que
dans la formation continue y ait de quoi
comprendre de quel problème on parle
donc j'insiste là dessus il ya des
endroits où on peut avoir des effets de
levier qui sont pas négligeables
parce que la réaction qui a déjà été
décrites par mélanie c'est à dire une
fois qu'on sait en tombe de sa chaise
elle peut s'observer chez les adultes
pas juste chez les enfants est une bonne
manière de provoquer ça chez les adultes
c'est dans le cadre du travail
on n'a pas donc ça on l'a abordée aussi
informé dans les entreprises et au
niveau du service national universel qui
va être mis en place la faudrait il faut
prévoir un temps de formation sur le
climat moi je suis quand même un peu
étonné de dire que quand tu dis que
c'est obligatoire parce qu'il ya
justement eu tout un mouvement notamment
menée par valérie masson delmotte qui
dit qu'il faut absolument inclure les
enjeux climat biodiversité et puis cela
me truc autour du conseil supérieur des
programmes où ils ont voulu
ils ont invité des climato sceptiques il
ya aussi un sujet de formation des
enseignants c'est à dire que une fois
qu'on a dit que c'était dans les
programmes
il faut que les enseignants eux mêmes et
le temps de regarder ce qu'ils doivent
enseigner de sa culture et c'est donc
tout ça est lent et si les programmes
sont définies par l'état
les supports de formation eux et ils
sont pas des îles sont pas mis à
disposition dans la foulée donc ça veut
dire que les gens sont un peu en mode
des maires de toi voilà donc cesser
c'est pas aussi simple que ça on prend
encore deux questions que je ne vais pas
toujours bonjour j bonjour yviers mot
donc seulement shifters et membre de
l'association des directeurs financiers
sur mon entreprise je reviens sur la
question de de la formation initiale que
vous avez eu la claque du point e
week-end comment est-elle comment
est-elle faite et qui qui faisait cette
formation parce que c'est le sujet
important la formation et l'information
alors on a vu valérie masson delmotte
qui nous est expliqué le réchauffement
climatique donc je pense que c'était pas
mal déjà
ensuite tout le monde n'a pas pris une
claque faut pas non plus
enfin moi je n'ai pas pris une claque
que j'étais au courant et alors si vous
voulez voir exactement comment ça s'est
passé toutes les vidéos sont sur le site
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat toutes les vidéos public donc ça
quand on est à 150 on est tous on est
filmé et retransmis donc vous allez
pouvoir c'est en fait je me souviens pas
tout parce qu'on a eu en tout plus de
100 intervenants depuis le début dont
jean marc est passé six minutes pas
rester longtemps
mais après on a bu un coup ensemble
c'était bien mais ouais voilà on a eu
100 plus de 100 d'intervenants donc je
me souviens plat de pâtes tout le monde
je sais que c'était valérie masson
delmotte qui nous c'est elle qui nous a
fait donc ouais il y en a beaucoup qui
sont tombés de leur chaise à ce moment
là bon après la dernière j'ai une
remarque parce que j étais comme disait
l'autre
le jour où je suis passé j'ai eu dans
l'axé à la fois il remarqué une question
j'ai trouvé que l'intervention de
laurent michel
c'est à dire le patron de la dged et est
totalement inutile parce que au lieu de
vous parler du problème à traiter il
vous embrouiller l'esprit avec tout un
tas de points de détails sur la
réglementation qu'il avait strictement
aucun intérêt à mon avis pour le travail
que vous avez à faire est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce point de vue
elle est d'accord mais je pense qu'il
faut passer la dernière question juste
pour des ans comprenait à peine ce
qu'ils disent est en fait très gentil ce
monsieur mais ok donc la dernière
question je sais pas où j'allais qui est
le micro
non bonjour xavier m'a dit je voudrais
juste revenir sur un point
jean-marc vous avez dit vous a cité de
gagner du temps c'est une stratégie pour
gagner du temps ce que vous pourriez
préciser quand vous savez pas quoi faire
une très bonne manière de montrer que
vous agissez sans rien faire c'est de
créer une commission ou de créer un
organisme ou de créer n'importe quoi en
disant j'écouterai avec attention ce que
ces gens là vous me racontez donc je
pense que c'est une manoeuvre dilatoire
quand vous avez des idées très très
clairs sur ce que vous avez envie de
faire vous le faites donc il ya un
certain nombre de sujets sur lequel
notre président a les idées très claires
sur ce qu'il a envie de faire donc il
n'a pas dit qu'il allait faire une
commission il a dit qu'il allait faire
ça peut être une connerie c'est pas le
sujet mais au moins il dit qui sait ce
qu'il veut faire et donc il le fait là
on voit bien qu'ils tâtonnent
d'abord il a été chercher hulot il doit
pas fait grand chose
ensuite il est en fait les éléments les
conflits les colombiens des points de
sondes qu' à mon niveau je peux avoir en
ayant discuté avec des gens qui sont
dans l'entourage du gouvernement en
place soit déconseillé et soit quelques
ministres sous etc montrent qu' il se
cherche c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont si je suis un peu cash dans les
grandes lignes toujours pas compris pour
les maltraiter et par ailleurs comme ils
n'ont pas compris pour les maltraiter et
qui n'ont pas réfléchi avant de rentrer
en fonction ils ont pas un truc clair
dans leur esprit qui est on va faire ça
pas ça ça passe à etc
vous voyez bien que c'est tout ça donc
il ya trois machin qui sont distribués à
droite et à gauche mais il n'y a pas de
ligne claire
un truc parmi d'autres qui le montrent
au moment où notre dame des landes a été
arrêté sauf erreur de ma part le mot
climat n'a pas été prononcé dans le
discours d' edouard philippe
alors que c'était quand même un truc en
fait je dire c'était gros comme c'était
défendant la pièce quoi bon
voilà donc ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui je
pense qu'ils ont juste à la rue et donc
ils gagnent du temps parce que s'il
savait quoi faire et nous sortir un
petit 49 3 pour le climat mais pas avant
donc malheureusement on doit arrêter les
questions et sauf moi j'ai encore le
droit d'imposer rigide qui m'a été
soufflée par jean-noël donc pour passer
à l'action qu'est ce qui vous paraît à
chacun de vous le plus facile de là où
vous êtes en tant que citoyen en tant
que président du shift ou en tant que
membre du hpc pour jean marc et mélanie
de quelle place puisque l'âge on a bien
compris que tu vois pas parler en tant
que membres du ccc pour l'instant de la
ccc mais voilà à quel moment tu vas
pouvoir
passez à l'action est ce qu'il faudra
attendre la fin de la cccs
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on attend
que les mesures soient validées à 150
s'il a peut-être qu'ils vont disparaître
et amendé acceptée au premier coup après
ce qu'il faut faire dès aujourd'hui je
vais me répéter c'est informer et
communiquer sur le shifter ce qu'ils y
font leur boulot là c'est super mais
faut pas faire que dans les grandes
villes et à paris a sablé voyez je vous
ai dit les gens étaient super contente
on a même il y avait d'ailleurs tous que
je l'informent à lyon il y avait un
climat perron en même temps ils étaient
entre 80 et 100 nous on était 150 à
sablé donc s'il y avait eu 1 % de la
population lyonnaise qui était venu au
climat perron de lyon ça aurait été bien
mais là donc les gens sont demandeurs
ils attendent d'ici y veulent ils
veulent savoir ce qui se passe donc faut
pas hésiter à communiquer informer la
population
ok donc donc mélanie informer
communiquer parler parler du climat jean
marc y aller il ya les deux à la fois
alors moi j'en ai marre d'entendre
parler de sable et je suis allé à loudun
c'est la moitié de la population de
sable et un bon et ils étaient 500 vous
n'avez pas voulu venir à sa b1 exige lui
dis ouais parce que le week end je fait
relâche
mais un autre jour je viendrai avec
plaisir donc le
non juste il ya en fait il faut il faut
jouer sur deux tableaux il ya un tableau
information qui aujourd'hui reste un
truc absolument essentiel et moi je suis
je suis rassuré d'avoir entendu mélanie
dire que les gens ont envie de
comprendre parce que je pense que c'est
la première contrepartie qu'on a à
offrir à des gens qui par ailleurs vont
se prendre une claque
c'est à dire le découvrir la situation
est la difficulté d'avoir à la gérer ces
c'est difficile psychologiquement et à
ce moment là la seule contrepartie qu'on
peut offrir
c'est d'arriver à faire en sorte que des
gens comprennent des trucs qu'ils
sentent confusément mais qui n'arrive
pas à décrire et articulé donc il ya
sarah et puis la deuxième chose c'est
quand même de réfléchir un peu au moment
où on communique à avoir déjà les
embranchements pour l'action c'est à
dire les trucs auxquels il faut
réfléchir de façon un peu concrète une
fois qu'on réalise la situation parce
que si on dit juste aux gens
il ya un gros problème il faut se bouger
et puis claque on s'arrête là on laisse
quand même un peu les gens en l'air et
là on va déclencher des réactions de
dénis donc il faut quand même avoir un
peu travaillé à l'avance sur les pistes
dans lesquels on peut partir ce qu'on
essaye de faire aux chiffres ce qu'on
essaye de faire dans mon métier par
ailleurs non pas que le chiffre soit pas
un vrai métier mais à 44 et donc le il
faut faire les deux les deux ans les
deux en parallèle de mon point de vue il
ya à la fois un sujet d'explication qui
reste encore 13 très imparfaite et là
puisque 1 1 dans la salle j'en fais mon
couplet sur les médias qui sont
absolument pas à la hauteur
de la diffusion d'une information qui
permet à la population dans son ensemble
de comprendre de quoi il retourne
et par ailleurs il ya un vrai sujet de
travail sur des pistes concrètes
parce que si on fait pas les deux en
même temps on perd beaucoup de gens en
cours de route ok on arrête là non
[Applaudissements]